das bundesministerium für
bevölkerungsentwicklung informiert liebe
bio deutschen mitbürger unsere politik
muss sich endlich wieder am bild der
klassischen familie orientieren
das heißt man frau kinder und mindestens
ein heterosexueller und ausdrücklich
keine familien sind mann/frau frau mann
ohne frau oder thermomix behaupten dass
hier die sogenannte alleinerziehende ein
ausdruck des scheiterns eines
lebensentwurfs computerbild du willst
gescheitert weil du deinen alten
konntest du [ __ ]
die werden auch nicht mehr gefördert
wenn wir hier das sagen haben
nein priorität hat die erhaltung des
stabs volk deshalb fordert die ard auch
ein baby begrüßungsgeld sagen wir und
das beuteschema pro baby hat auch bei
den ossis auch funktioniert also find
ich nicht
wir verlangen dass ab sofort bei
scheidungen die schuldfrage wieder
geklärt wird
stichwort schwerwiegendes fehlverhalten
gegen die eheliche solidarität wenn also
zum beispiel die alte nicht mehr dass
ich schon längst hätte wieder ein bier
holen müssen
die uhr tickt verleihen
was macht eine frau die vor einem leeren
blatt papier sitzt und liegt die
studiert ihre rechte seine frau weine
warum haben frauen ihre tage weil sie es
verdient haben
der trend zur selbstabschaffung der
deutschen muss endlich gestoppt werden
unser vorschlag eine bundesweite
masturbation polizei bürger in
deutschland kann es sich nicht leisten
so kostbares erbgut zu verschwinden
deswegen reist zusammen mit kaffee
[Musik]
martin